a minister the department for exiting
the EU and good morning to you good
morning and so the debate is going to
get underway today about cereza maize
withdrawal agreement do you agree with
Richard theis that effectively we are
just heading for a No Deal because it
doesn't look like the Prime Minister is
going to get hurt deals true in the
meaningful vote this time next week no I
think what we have before us is a deal
that many people said would be
impossible where they is offering us a
free trade deal better than they offered
to any other third country outside the
EU where we are delivering on our
commitments you know hard border in the
island of Ireland and when we are taking
control of our money our borders and our
laws I think this is a deal in the
national interest and I think when MPs
debate it and discuss it in detail they
need to think about their constituencies
the prosperity of the people that they
represent and I think at the end of the
day they will want to back this deal
today well everybody is talking about is
the backstop suggestions that this deal
we're getting could see us in that
backstop forevermore that's the major
problem that a lot of MPs have with
Theresa Mays deal that they'll be
talking about today in the House of
Commons and I think clearly there are
concerns about the backstop and you know
I think it's clear what the Attorney
General made clear yesterday is that the
backstop is comfortable for neither side
over the UK nor the EU and that
therefore it's in the best interests of
both parties to avoid it coming into
force I agree with that and I think it's
clear in the terms of the future
declaration but there are alternatives
to the backstop but we can put in place
to avoid it ever coming into force the
best one of those is to actually make
sure that the the dripper deal the
future relationship between the UK and
the EU is in place by December 2020 if
we can do that we can ensure actually
that the backstop never needs to be used
at all and you being held in contempt of
Parliament today that's being debated
because you refused to publish the full
legal advice behind the Prime Minister's
deal why don't you just publish it
because this is just frustrating the
process and delaying everything you're
having to go through all of this this
morning before we can get down to the
business of the deal itself why not just
publish
so what the government did yesterday was
to publish very detailed legal position
on the withdrawal agreement to set that
all out in detail on paper for MPS to
read and and furthermore to make the
Attorney General available to answer
questions for more than two hours in
Parliament that's something that hasn't
happened since the 1980s I think the
Attorney General was very frank and open
in answering questions about legal
advice but he also made clear that his
legal advice to cabinet is privileged it
is information that has to be in the
context of an ongoing negotiation as it
was at the time and therefore there is
various some content of that but may not
be in the national interest to publish I
think it's vital but ministers respect
their duty towards the national interest
whilst national interests the letting
the people who voted for brexit know all
the details and that's exactly what we
did with the document that we published
yesterday we've published that
withdrawal agreement in full we
published at the political declaration
we've published a legal analysis of the
withdrawal agreement if you're taking
legal advice on behalf of the people of
the UK surely they should be in
possession of all the facts it's a very
well-established principle but when
government takes advice and when cabinet
takes advice in particular it does so on
a confidential basis and that advice
needs to be able to be frank in the
context of a negotiation of course in
the context of negotiation there is some
information which it's not sensible to
put in the public domain and to
Telegraph to the other side and actually
Kirsten we recognized this during the
debate today was if you lose this today
are you going to publish the full legal
advice I don't think the government is
going to lose this today because I think
at the end of the day MPs on all sides
will wrecking the debate that there is
some information that has to be
protected and I think what we saw was a
classic parliamentary trick from Labour
where during the course of the debate
Kier made all sorts of concessions that
all sorts of things wouldn't have this
you're saying you think you will well I
think what the what the government is
will you publish this at legal what the
government has made clear is if a motion
were carried we believe that the
appropriate way forward will be for the
Committee on privileges to have a look
at the the whole issue of contempt and
whether that was robia but to be clear I
don't think there has been
contemp we've been in Parliament
answering questions being very no it's
not it's not your opinion that cows it's
the debate that counts today so if you
do lose this will you publish our legal
advice in fall the attorney general was
absolutely clear that publishing the
full legal advice that he gave cam that
would not be in the national interest he
has a responsibility under the
ministerial code to keep that
information confidential but what we
have published is full legal analysis of
the withdrawal agreement I think now is
what Parliament needs